heyo clixoom erhofft was geht ab dass
sie jetzt sondereinsatz ak papa sondern
ich finde gerade live in der haut und
ich habe meine frage für mich haben will
was hältst du von einem kleinen größer
auf gangster mal vermachen aber in
wirklichkeit gar keine gangster sind
würde sie lieber männer ak 47 27 oder
lieber doch gleich mit der ganzen
panzerfaust weg bayern alles klar dass
wir meine frage für dich ich muss jetzt
ja auch wieder weiter geschäfte machen
mit scheinbare verstehst realität
ok teufel nur so wie immer lustiger tabu
was man heute keine gangster sind
interessiert mich alles gar nicht ich
will gar nicht wissen nichts von den und
ich will es auch gar nichts wissen es
interessiert mich gar nicht ich habe
keine zeit für sowas teufel im ball ja
auch ein bisschen lustiger typ auf jeden
fall